PROFESSOR: So let's do
a connection formula
and use it to solve a problem.
The derivation of such
connection formulas,
we'll face it the next time.
And we'll go further
applications of the methods.
So, yes.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE] that
problem like [INAUDIBLE] where
the wave function vanished.
Is that a problem of the
[? our ?] perturbation
or a classical problem?
Because at that point,
then it means the kinetics
and the potential are
equals to each other.
So like the potential cannot
be bigger than the energy,
then that's a classical thing.
That's not a
perturbation problem.
PROFESSOR: Right.
This is not a problem of
the perturbation theory.
It's just our lack of
knowledge, our ignorance of how
the solution looks near there.
So there's nice WKB
formulas for this solution
away from the turning points.
Those are this.
But the solutions near
the turning points
violate the semiclassical
approximation.
Therefore, you have to find
the solution near the turning
points by any method you have.
That is not going to be
the semiclassical method.
And then you will
find the continuation.
Now, there's several
ways people do this.
The most down to
earth method, which
is I think the method we're
going to use next time,
is trying to solve the thing
near there, the solution.
People that are
more sophisticated
use complex variables,
methods in which they
think of the solution
in the complex plane,
the x plane becomes complex.
And they're coming
to the turning point
and they go off
the imaginary axis
to avoid it and come
on the other side.
It's very elegant,
very nice, harder
to make very precise, and a
little difficult to explain.
I don't know if
I'll try to do that.
But it's a nice thing.
It's sort of
avoiding the turning
point by going off the axis.
It sounds crazy.
So here is a connection formula.
Here is x equals a.
Here is v of x.
And here is a solution for
x less than a, little a,
I'll write it like
that, p of x cosine x
to a kappa k of x vx prime
minus pi over 4 minus B
over square root of
p of K of x sine x
to a k of x prime vx
prime minus pi over 4.
So look, this is a general
solution in allowed region.
[INAUDIBLE] no, it doesn't
look like what you wrote here.
But sines and cosines are linear
combinations of these things.
And why do I put this
silly minus pi over 4?
Because that's what
my solutions connect
to solutions on the other side.
Which is to say that the
solution on the other side,
people that work this
connection formulas,
discovered that takes
this form, a to x
kappa of x prime vx prime plus
b over the square root of kappa
of x e exponential a to x
kappa of x prime vx prime.
So here it is.
Those numbers, a
and b, are things
you have to keep track now.
They say if your solution
for x greater [INAUDIBLE]
has this decaying exponential
and this growing exponential
with b an a, your
solution far to the left
will look like this.
It's a pretty strange statement.
Sometimes you don't
want b to be 0.
Sometimes you do.
Let's do an example
with this stuff
so that you can
appreciate what goes on.
So that's your first look
at a connection condition.
There's a little bit of
subtleties on how to use them.
We will discuss those
subtleties next time, as well.
But let's use it in a case
where we can make sense of this
without too much trouble.
So here is the example.
And somebody wants you to
solve the following problem.
You have some slowly
varying potential
that grows, grows indefinitely.
v of x.
And you wish to find
the energy eigenstates.
In particular, you wish
to find the energies.
What are the possible
energies of this potential?
This potential with have
a infinite wall here.
So the potential
is infinite here.
And it grows like
that up on this side.
We're going to try to write
the solution for this.
So we'll do this with
the WKB solution.
And let me do it in
an efficient way.
So what do we have here?
This is the analog of
our point x equals a.
Is that right?
This is the point where the
turning solution goes funny.
So we will call it, for the
same reason we did before,
this point a will
make matters clearer.
We truly don't know
what that point
is because we truly don't know
what are the allowed energies.
But so far we can write E as
a variable that we don't know.
And a can be determined if
you know E because you know
the shape of the potential.
OK.
So let's think of the region,
x much greater than a.
We are here.
We're in a forbidden region.
And the potential is
still slowly varying.
Let's assume that
slope is small.
So a solution of this
type would make sense.
So we must have a WKB solution
on this right hand side
to the right of x equals a.
And that's the most general
solution we'll have.
On the other hand,
here there's two types
of solutions, a growing
exponential and a decaying
exponential.
And we must have only
the decaying exponential.
Because this
potential never turns.
If this potential would grow
here and then turn down,
you might have what is
called the tunneling problem.
And this has to be rethought.
But this problem is
still a little easier.
We have just this
potential growing forever.
And on the right, we
must have b equal to 0.
For x greater than a
solution, b is equal to 0.
And this solution must
have a different from 0.
But if the solution
has a different from 0,
we now know the
solution on this region,
x significantly less than a.
In this region we
know the solution is
given by that formula up there.
So our solution for x much
less than a, the solution
must take the form
whatever a is.
1, 2, 3.
I kind of normalized
these things yet.
So the solution, I'll write it,
psi of x, will be of the form 1
over square root of
k of x cosine of x
to a k of x prime vx
prime minus pi over 4.
All right.
That's what WKB predicts because
of the connection condition.
On the forbidden region,
you know which wave exists.
And therefore, far to the
left of the turning point,
you'd also know
the wave function.
It's the term within a.
So have we solved the problem?
Well, I don't think we have.
We still don't know the energy,
so we must have not solved it.
In fact, it doesn't look
like we've solved it at all.
Because at x equals 0,
these wave functions
should vanish because
there's a hard wall.
And I don't see any reason
why it would vanish.
So let's do a little
work here expanding this
and orienting it
a little better.
So I want to write this
integral from 0, x to a.
You're having an integral.
You have 0, x, and a.
Because we are in the
x less than a region,
this integral is the
one that we have here.
I'll write it as
an integral from 0
to a minus an
integral from 0 to x.
So integral from x to
a is equal to integral
from 0 to a minus an
integral from 0 to x.
This will make things
a little clearer.
In fact, we could do things
still a little easier.
So what do we have here?
We have this exponential,
the wave function.
Not an exponential, a
trigonometric function.
1 over square root of k of x
cosine of minus the integral
from 0 to x of k of x dx prime.
This integral gives
rise to two integrals
and I wrote the first.
Then I come with
the other [? sine ?]
plus the integral from 0
to a of k prime of x dx
prime minus pi over 4.
And let's call this thing delta.
So let's explore this wave
function a little more.
So things have
become kind of nice.
There's no x dependence here.
That's very nice about
this part of the formula.
This is an angle.
No x dependence.
And the x dependence is
just here from this term.
And it's a nice x dependence
because it's an integral from 0
to x.
So it's kind of nice.
The upper limit has the x.
It's all kind of elegant.
So trigonometric
function of this cosine
of a difference of things
is equal to its cosine
of the first term, 0 to x k of
x prime dx prime cosine delta
plus sine of the first term 0
to x k of x prime dx prime sine
delta.
You have this quantity
and this delta.
So I use this trigonometric sum.
OK.
But now you can
see something nice.
What did we say about
the wave function?
It had to vanish at the origin.
And let's look at
these two functions.
Which one vanishes
at the origin?
You have cosine of
the integral from 0
to x when x is equal to
0 at the origin is cosine
of 0, which is 1.
On the other hand, when
x is small, x goes to 0.
You get 0 for the integral
and the sine vanishes.
So this is the right term.
So this wave function
would be correct
if this term would be absent.
This is a term that
you must make absent.
Psi of x without that term
would be a valid wave function.
It is the wave function.
Therefore, the
right wave function
if we demand that cosine
delta be equal to 0.
So now we're imposing a
very non-trivial condition.
This wave over there.
This contribution to the
argument, to the angle
here, this delta must be
such that cosine delta is 0.
In which case, this
term would disappear
and we would have a
good wave function.
Psi of x, if this is true,
is 1 over square root
of k of x times sine times
the sine delta, which
is another number.
Sine of 0 to x k of
x prime dx prime.
So we need cosine
delta equal to 0.
You know, this
argument gives you
this wave function in a nice
way here written what it is.
But we would have been able
to find this even faster.
If you just demand that
Psi at x equals 0 is 0,
you must have that this thing,
the integral from 0 to a
of this quantity minus pi
over 4 must have 0 cosine.
And that's the
condition we did fine.
The advantage of
our rearrangement
is that when that happens,
the whole wave function
looks like that.
And that's kind of nice.
That gives you the picture
of the wave function.
A fairly accurate picture of the
wave function in this region.
Not very near the turning
point, but you got that.
So what is this cosine
delta going to 0?
Well then delta must be
2n plus 1 times pi over 2.
So the places where the
cosine is 0 is pi over 2.
That's for n equals 0.
3 pi over 2.
So for n equal 1.
And it just goes.
The vertical axis
and the unit circle.
So this is for n equals 0,
1, 2, 3, goes on and on.
And this is a very
wonderful condition.
This says that the integral
from 0 to a of k of x prime dx
prime minus pi over 4.
So actually, we have here
you can multiply the 2 here.
You get an n.
And then you have pi over 2.
And the pi over 4 that
comes from that term
becomes n plus 3/4 pi.
It's a Bohr-Sommerfeld
quintessential condition.
Look, I box that equation
because that really
gives you the answer.
Now, why?
Because you know what k is.
k p of x is equal to
h bar k is square root
of 2n E minus v of x.
And if you know E, you know a.
So you have now an integral.
And you take, for
example, n equals 0.
So you want the integral
to be equal to 3/4 pi.
But you will have to
start changing the value
of the energy with your computer
if you cannot do the integral
analytically and find, oops,
for this value of the energy
the integral of what I know,
this is a known function,
gives me this value.
So this is a very practical way
of finding the energy levels.
It does give you the
approximate energy levels.
And it's remarkably
accurate in many cases.
It also has a little
intuition this
is for n equals 0 would
be like the ground state.
n equal 1 first take
on excited states.
And indeed, that makes sense.
Because this integral
from 0 to a of k
is the total phase
of the wave function
as you move from 0 to a.
And that wave is a
number of factor n
times pi plus a little bit.
So it has time for m 0s.
The phase as you move from
0 to a in the wave function,
the sine function will
have n 0s if this condition
is satisfied consistent
with that solution.
So that's it.
We'll continue next time.
Find the solution
of WKB exactly.
All right.